okay so christine is calling in
christina what happened
i am so i hate being single
i hate being single so bad today's topic
um we got a video here from skippy i've
watched a skippy video in a minute
someone sent me this one's unlisted
i have been looking and looking and
looking to try and get a date for the
kenny chesney concert
which is tonight i've called all my
a-list
friends the girls that i know that i
find to be extremely attractive
and available and amazing and none of
them could go
like not a single one and none of them
could go
none of them could go none of them could
go maybe they were busy maybe they were
busy
i'm gonna just say this there is
something very interesting about the
fact that he defines them as like very
good friends and the first thing he
defines them by is how attractive they
are
and that's how they're a-list you know
like when i think of going somewhere
with my friends i don't think about how
attractive they are i think of like
who am i going to get along with and
it's going to make the experience better
that's a good friend how she a good
friend
i want to bang her really bad yeah it's
interesting i
i've been checking for a few weeks now
right well uh
it's crunch time we're at 4 40 the
concert's at like 7 30 or something like
that
and i've now posted like four or five
messages on facebook i know that i can
get an
ugly girl to go with me so i don't want
to just settle right and i've had guy
friends you know even joke one jokingly
[Laughter]
yo you know when i talk to you about the
whole idea of like male and women being
friends
most of the time i'm talking about dudes
like this yeah
i swear if you're talking about dudes
like yeah i see what you're saying
oh oh
oh yeah yeah
you live in your mom's basement this is
not a meme you literally do
he's got a belly button lint collection
here's my poster of the osmonds and over
here
is my belly button went collection
[Music]
he dressed up and dragged to go with me
and that's not the point of this i want
to go with someone that i'm attracted to
that there's
a chance so no one that's married should
be going with me
guy or girl right and um there should be
at least a chance that there's some
chemistry right guy or girl because now
he's desperate
because now he's just you know what
you're not
yeah well listen dude
you're taken and your girl's taken too
cuz
you imagine they get a divorce and he's
hitting on both of them yeah
because you know why not okay so let me
tell you
how this went down so there was this
girl that i found
online that said that she could go
and this was at like 5 30 ish right 6 30
comes around
i call her no answer goes straight to
voicemail i call her a second time
straight to voicemail i'm waiting i go
online and i start looking
and i even said no excuse me to work
so that i on the hopes of this and then
finally i see this girl that i've had a
crush on for a while
uh but she's given me a let's just be
friends sock and so i've kind of settled
into okay there will never be anything
there
now get this with her okay her
thing is uh she asks me uh
yeah i can come um but can i
you don't mind if i take off a little
early so as soon as we get done she
wants me to drop her
off at the drive-in movie so her and her
real date tonight
can go to it but she doesn't mind
pushing him back in lieu of being able
to go to the concert so that's what's
going on
yeah because it's not a date skippy i'm
gonna say this
she says she's it's not a date so she's
gonna go back to you and be like you
know yeah let's go see this movie
whatever we're still friends
so you skippy shouldn't take that as a
date
on the other hand don't stay friends
with people that stay friends with you
just because they want to pay you
don't do that don't true
don't do that it goes both ways for some
people that's it that doesn't exist
you put yourself in the friend zone sure
but if you know you're seeing friends
and that person always lingering and in
the hopes of
don't stay friends with that person cut
it off but how am i going to get my free
concert tickets
exactly exactly
exactly yes that
as much as we want to blame skippy that
no wait are you saying she's using her
position of power
over him to get free stuff no because
she doesn't have a position of power
he has a position of power he has a
camera but you don't see the power
dynamics in this one
and she's just taking free things he has
the power she cannot have the power
okay why would she have the power how
could she have the power i just thought
that
sometimes attractive women have power
over them no they don't ever
it's just okay no is she a man so
now what i'm going to do is i'm going
sorry i'm on some pity today i know me
too
is she a man no can't happen
petty petty girl that i was supposed to
go
on a date with and uh leave a voice
message
and tell her what i think of her
um and maybe we'll even get a chance to
uh
talk to her on the phone but i doubt it
so
here we go
hi christina it's uh skippy and you'll
notice that on facebook
i deleted you as a friend because i
think that you were a giant
[ __ ]
so
i agree with the floor
i agree with the floor the floor is
right on that one good job yeah i agree
with you
yeah uh everything you said floor
everything you said
i feel like toxic is the is the only i
don't know i don't know
yeah you know what's crazy though you
know it's crazy you see this in movies
sometimes people get voice messaging you
hear about stuff like this
me personally i've never heard it
because i again i'm not a woman and i
don't
you know they don't send me i've had
people tell me that these kinds of
things happen
um it's just wild to hear someone just
said like
you [ __ ] bitching all this other
stuff like
someone rejects you just move on with
your day you know and
you set up everything to get rejected as
also
yeah guys this is exactly how you don't
take a rejection if someone
stands you up they're not that into you
if someone responds to something you
said and they're like yeah i'll be there
and then they'd lie
and they're not that into you people who
are into you're gonna make an effort
so when you take this you take this huge
like blow when you feel the need to like
get back at them
you don't look good you make yourself
look dumber they're not that into you
and you only look more desperate and
angry and that energy that you give off
is going to push more people away
that resentful thing super weak so
yeah on this part man yo skippy be doing
some crazy stuff
like beta and don't think it's just him
there's a lot of other people who do
stuff like this
that's beta right there by going to
sleep and then
not like and i get the accidents happen
don't get me wrong
and that might even be nope that's not
you calling in someone else
um but i get that you were trying
to uh you imagine if it was her calling
saying hey skippy sorry i just woke up
but i'm ready i'm just getting dressed
right now okay cool i'll see you in like
20 minutes then she hangs up
she hits the voice message she hears
that
you were gonna take a nap or something
like that anyway so my whole deal is
this phone call is to tell you that
you're a [ __ ] and i really don't want
to talk to you again
even if you have a great excuse
you promised i was pretty mean with that
right but i'm pissed
that should not happen and now i guess
yeah now i'm a big dick but uh
i don't know
i am i'm a really bitter kid right now i
hate
right now
right now only hey man if you see
yourself
in any of this behavior yeah just try to
correct it listen at the end of the day
it's not like i sit here and i want
terrible things for skippy or anybody
else like you know
there are certain behaviors that you
engage in that will contribute to your
own demise and i think it's important
for us to recognize that
that stuff hurts the people around us
and hurts us ourselves so there is some
responsibility to be better um when i
watch skippy doing this stuff i'm just
like bruh
can't be doing that i hate being single
i hate being single so bad the only the
only reason why
i'm like why i don't just like lower my
standards and go out with and go after
like
a girl that i'm not attracted to at all
or
um change my standards and go for
a girl that uh would probably go out
with me but isn't
anywhere near what i consider my type
the only reason that i do all that is
because
i have the hope that on the horizon that
there's something better right
so you just like go okay this is just a
phase i'm going through well this
phase has been going on for 33
years okay now the first you know 16
shouldn't count but
okay so 17 years of my life
has just been okay in two years for a
mormon mission
do you expect me to have sympathy for
you is that what i'm supposed to i'm so
oh
17 years lower your standards what do
you want me to tell you
lower your standards i would say this to
a woman i would say this to you as well
it's like
if you go on to the dating world and the
people you keep trying to go afterwards
are not interested in you it's either
one of two things all right either your
standards are too high
okay if it's 17 years worth of rejection
either your standards are way too high
okay and you need to humble yourself or
two
the problem is your behavior when you
engage in these relationships and you
need to humble yourself and look at your
own behavior it's one of those two
things
you're like oh the dating sucks no you
suck
you're the problem because at the end of
the day if it's been 17 years
17 years and it's been consistent that
you've been having the same results for
17 years
the common denominator is you you're the
common denominator in all those
situations
so you have to change your behavior i
don't know how to say it to you but it
is what it is
okay and it doesn't matter how long it's
been going 17 years i don't care
i've been i've been uh going to the
bathroom
and taking dumps for 38 years um
i'm planning on doing that for a couple
of other years it's still [ __ ] that's
gonna come out of my ass
don't matter how long you do it
it's what you do if you were on the job
market and you were applying to a bunch
of jobs for 17 years and got rejected
every time
i want to get a job that pays me 20 and
none of them hired you
maybe you got to take a job that only
pays 15 an hour that's what we would
tell you as grown adults
there's nobody who would feel sympathy
for you if you were constantly looking
for that job and you never got it
so why would you think it's any
different from the marketplace it's
because people have this arrogant view
that they deserve
somebody you don't deserve anything
you're not owed anything in this world
you just get what you get so either put
in the work or stop crying
and it's in that job that job that
you're applying for you have to check
is your resume good you have the good
credentials yeah are you
how do you go to are you even applying
are you how are you applying
are you even applying [ __ ] are
talking about i wish i could win the
lottery
and you never buy a ticket boo you don't
even know how to play the goddamn game
for a mormon mission so 50 what's that
15 years
15 years of my life of horrible luck
with the ladies you know some have a gun
okay so christina's calling in so that's
what you call me
christina what happened i
am so so sorry
um my phone died planning on going with
you i did not know why i was
dead like i really
am sick like i have been dealing
with these sleeping issues all week and
then killing myself
physically and i i'm sick i'm
lightheaded i was gonna go to a concert
with you
and i said well i think it would be fun
to just talk to you and you should know
and you have a great personality
i wasn't going to concert because i was
excited to go at the concert honestly
dark light i kind of have a headache of
migraine dark lights
movies whole
settings sounded great but then you want
to all go
um and then on it's even worse
when i'm tired i get distracted and
things
like this happen i can understand how
you keep
that i think that a little bit
[Music]
well hey my date just got here so i'm
gonna hang up but uh
take care and uh yeah
this is the girl i was supposed to go
with okay uh take care bye
you thought you were petty you thought
you were petty
and then skippy went home my beer
hold my margarita hold my sangria
i'm about to take you to petty town
time won't you take me to bed
remember watching recess remember
watching recess in the snitch
yeah i need to get a wedge every now and
then and you'll be like yeah good
there's certain kids you just look at me
throw them over
when yeah and then he falls around yeah
and you're like
yeah yeah yeah you bump your head that's
right
that's what you get that's what i mean
you bring that ass energy onto your next
date this woman walks in she's like yo
what's wrong with this
bruh and you know the worst part is like
when you leave all these experiences on
a bad term you know
word gets around people talk oh so you
ruined the rest of your dating pool as
well
guys like i said when you take a
rejection we did another video on
another guy who gets rejected
take it like him walk away as best as
you can take a l take it hold it high
be like you know what that's mine that's
right and then
keep it moving and then if you catch the
second one you're going to turn it
around and make it a w that's it
that's it chad skippy needs to meet chad
yep yeah skippy needs to meet chad
remember chad yeah yep whenever the girl
was trying to play and he's like all
right cool
whatever yeah and he went with it yeah
but and i'm sure ted got a bunch of dms
after that
guaranteed guarantee you want to
advertise yourself that's one good way
to do it take the l
like a champ yeah okay and that's not
even a dating thing that's an everything
life
everyday life thing like you go to a job
you know i mean you go for an interview
they reject you don't walk out cursing
everybody and
getting mad because you didn't get them
i didn't want that job anyway because
guess what
they might call you back in the future
to hire you that's happened numerous
times
guess what when you piss off that
recruiter who happens to be the one who
recruits safe well that recruiter
sometimes has to recruit for other
companies so it might come back to bite
you then
walk away so cleanly you know she was
generous with her excuse
and she was what's kinder than i would
have been and someone left me the kind
of
toxic stuff that he did um but yeah
maybe she also did so for her own safety
who knows yeah and she said you're
immature but that that yeah you don't
you know
you haven't known cuz the way he acting
it is immature
okay sorry it's really tough to hang up
on a person and
drive and video and video all at the
same time yeah i know
what's up skippy yeah i decided to uh
videotape the adventure of uh today okay
but yeah all right let's go do it
whose likes when you're in the club and
someone has to get here
my name's lisa huh
lisa and a little bit of slob comes out
and hits you on the side
me i always like looking at people
talking to the club because sometimes
you see one person being like this yeah
and the other person leaning again and
they just keep leaning
like this and pushing on this shoulder
right here and the person is really
trying to get away
and then you're like lisa
i like grinding on you without your
consent for 30 seconds
can i buy you a drink huh can i buy you
a drink
you know the best parts about going to
clubs is sometimes last call comes
around and the last call passes and they
turn on the lights
yeah and you see the girl you were
dancing with you like whoo
god damn oh you look different with
sweat and all this other stuff coming
down
you smell different too that [ __ ]
dip dip yeah definitely
and so now she's about to get out of my
car and leave for date number two
and he apparently did not know that you
were you're
on one day going to another and that's
why she was late
so uh have fun telling him about that
thanks for coming i don't know that he's
there watching us
right yeah now he's paying for her
though we're watching him pay for her
uh she doesn't want me video creeping
him but let's see that's
you no you can't see his face there's so
there he is paying for that
are we done bro my hand is an imprint of
my face because i face palm so much
my mans is bugging
my man slapped her own chastity belt on
his penis
i never heard of that i never heard a
man
slapping no chastity belt on the opinion
he then swallowed the key
no he didn't even swallow it man he he
thanos
because swallowing it means he has a
chance to get it out and dig it back out
my man made that disappear there's no
way he's coming out of the
virgin realm the shadow realm virgin
realm okay so that's the end of uh
date number one for you and you're on to
date number two and i'm on to a drive
home i'm on to kenny chesney
yeah yeah cause i because i of course
was billy uh carrington
let's go there's not much left let's get
this done
okay let last
is pretty hot even though he's just the
opening act
yeah right well he's no kenny i didn't
know who he was
and i was like he's pretty attractive
you know yeah yeah
okay well uh good luck good luck with
kenny okay thanks
here's the thing though i want to point
this out if
annella had made any
effort to have been cute and flirty and
everything like that now
granted i know that she wants to just be
friends and
i get that the nice thing was i was able
to stare at hot girls while i was on a
date with her
so that was nice i mean like really i
was able to like there was a girl in
front of us that had like a great butt
and i didn't
feel bad at all for looking at that
girl's butt
um because she was not my
date really she was just a friend
anyways but if she had made
a small effort to have been
a little bit flirty or something like
that then
um she would have gotten this and i'm
going to turn it on
oh ho ho check that out because i bought
one for me
and one potentially for her benella
he treated me too much like a guy friend
it wasn't really a date it was me
hanging out with a person that happened
to
have a right but didn't feel like a girl
thing or whatever even though annelise
man you know what you know what i'm
tripping man's a virgin i say good
you know i mean if you gonna be this
mean to other people
then you know whatever you get i'm just
not going to feel that bad for you you
ain't
yeah i hope you stay so go in nowhere
you ain't going nowhere it's like
you can't be stopped now cause you're a
virgin for life yo listen there's an
irony in the fact that he's like i
wouldn't go out with a
an ugly girl because that's lowering my
stance what do you think every hot girl
who get with you is doing
[Laughter]
not going out with you i mean not only
are you ugly in terms of your your
physical
looks but your personality oh yeah it's
all that is
is a zero out of ten you're very why you
ain't got no alibi
mommy why do you think you got that way
literally literally
listen oh mama listen this one would say
okay you can either lower your standards
or you can die alone all right all right
so buy a dog buy a cat buy a lizard
whatever it is that you want to do
collect lint die alone die virgin
that's how it be i have zero zero
zero sympathy none for people who
arrogantly go into the dating world
have absolutely no successes because the
fact that they're constantly chasing
beautiful people and it's really just
their behavior that makes exactly
that put them in that predicament yeah
yeah yeah so if you have standards are
too high and you can't
get any success that's your fault i'm
not gonna feel sympathy for you don't
expect it for me none and i'm pretty
sure you're not gonna get it for most
people so
if you're out there and you keep i can't
find any hot one lower your standards
that's it that's all i got and i hope
you stay single until you rectify your
waste because whoever gets to be in a
relationship with you that's going to be
what i'm terrified for
yeah that's going to be a big bad word
jesus freaking christ
yeah and the worst part is that you read
the comments you read the comments yeah
but anyways
that's it for today's video let us know
what you guys think did you guys enjoy
and if you guys enjoyed today's video
leave a like comment subscribe good
stuff all right
the audacity
[Music]
um
[Music]
me